oh is there a question about my hobbies
i see uh i see josh answering it for me
i appreciate that
oh there is a question from leonidas
cheering 100 bits asking what did i do
for exercise
um
[Music]
yeah recently like taking walks i
haven't played tennis in a while
i don't want to play tennis
okay i guess i'm playing e4 this game
yeah taking walks tennis stafford gambit
rook lifting
let's play a a roy lopez
i'm already out thank you for everything
you do
oh thank you for subbing
the rite of spring
yeah i don't know any theory here
which is kind of uncomfortable but
it's also kind of liberating i can just
wing it
and uh try and follow some
spanish principles like d4 looks
intriguing
as i gain tempo on the bishop and
d5 might be coming
and the reason to play d5
sooner
[Music]
to play d5 right now is black wants to
play d5
like there's a move knight c3 but after
d5
there's a line e5 bishop g4
that seems okay for black
if i play d5 first knight b8
and just have a nice space
advantage and i gain time
it's not winning by any means but
[Music]
a6
i'm thinking bishop here
there's bishop d3 as well
or bishop b2
i don't want to take because that would
just help black
you black the bishop hair
actually thinking
okay so assuming the knight goes back to
b8
i'm going to have this idea
on d6
and in that case the bishop might
actually be best on c4
um
i do invite knight a5 and then bishop e2
and then i'll be threatening pawn b4
let's play bishop c4 not the first move
that came to mind
or even the second move that came to
mind
my original considerations were these
three squares
but that's why it's important to
think ahead
okay so d6
yeah this is more intuitive
and there's a line takes queen takes
bishop c7
i was also thinking bishop f4
i'm in no rush to win back the pawn
and this bishop i mean these pieces are
a bit kind of stuck
i'll take there
if rookie 8 and f7 is going to be
under fire
probably this move
there's not too many ways for black to
effectively defend the pawn
like the only move i see is knight h8
what else to do
if queen f6 i win the bishop
yeah this position makes me happy
but still takes work can't celebrate too
soon
thinking 95
and just
continue to throw punches
i'm threatening uh
maybe not quite force mate but
just absolute destruction
hey it's taki what's up taki
i was wondering it's all these taggy
emotes
aggie says hello chat shortstop for me
or i thought he's working
oh i'll enjoy
enjoy your work
good to see you
we had a night another icelandic viewer
earlier
who's filling your
filling the tagi void
f4 looks fun here
because after it takes takes i open that
file
of course very soon i want to bring the
knight in
bring the other rook in
okay now i have three attackers
this knight is still kind of stuck
it's gonna be forever tied down
the queen is also now tied down
and this move is probably coming
although if i play this move i do have
to be ready for this move
but then knight b6 hitting the rook and
the pawn
yeah i'm not
uh
i don't really want to rely on like too
much calculation
[Music]
intuition is enough here
and there's some 95
and then maybe i have to calculate
this move
still some ideas of this stuff
i give knight g6 i do this and i
hit the pawn hit the rook
if that i just hop in
here
and meet
yeah this is a nice little uh wow it's
smother mate it's actually a pretty rare
type of smother mate
not too often that knight is just taking
away the
corner square from the king
that was a fun game though
like i was not at all
everything opening like bishop c5 is
is not a move i've studied
maybe i've looked at it once but then
forgot everything
but just relied on like basic plans and
figuring out
the
tactical lines
and that was a pretty clean game
it seemed like black maybe should play
like bishop b6 is very typical
but then still d4
ah then takes in d5
yeah so maybe it was better to delay
castling
you're lucky
during another 100 bits
oh is this our chest approved oh because
it's roy lopez
as a classical variation